>>> WELCOME
JESSE: WELCOME TO.
"WATTERS' WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
BY NOW EVERYBODY HEARD THE STORY
OF THE COVINGTON BOYS.
WE'LL HAVE A SIT-DOWN WITH A
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY WHO
STARTED THE WHOLE THING, THE
BLACK ISRAELITES.
PHILLIPS FIRST TOLD "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND OTHER
OUTLETS THAT HE WAS SURROUND AND
HARASS BID THE COVINGTON BOYS.
HE SAID THE BOYS WERE QUOTE
ATTACKING THESE FOUR BLACK
INDIVIDUALS.
HE CONTINUED, QUOTE, THESE YOUNG
MEN WERE BEATLY AND THESE OLD
BLACK INDIVIDUALS WAS THEIR
PREY.
PHILLIPS CALLED IT RACISM AND
THE HATRED IN THEIR CASES
RESEMBLED WHRIN MUCHING THAT
WERE DONE IN AMERICA.
HE SAID THE STUDENTS WERE
CHARNTING "BUILD THE WALL."
ONCE THE COMPLETE VIDEO WAS
RELEASED, EVERYTHING PHILLIPS
SAID WAS A LIE.
IT WAS PHILLIPS WHO APPROACHED
THE BOYS AND BANGED THE DRUM IN
HIS FACE.
NOBODY CHANTED "BUILD THE WALL."
IT LOOKS LIKE PHILLIPS AND HIS
CREW WERE THE AGGRESSORS WITH
THE
JESSE: AFTER THE CONFRONTATION
WITH THE BOYS HE ATTEMPTED TO
DISRESULT MASS AT WASHINGTON,
D.C.'S NATIONAL SHRINE.
PHILLIPS AND 20 DEMONSTRATORS
TRIED TO FORCE THEMSELVES INTO
EVENING MASS, BANG THEIR DRUMS
AND TOTALLY DIGS REPRESENT THE
SERVICE.
SECURITY CALLED THE SITUATION
QUOTE TENSE AND HAD TO BLOCKADE
PHILLIPS AND HIS CREW FROM
DISTURBING THE CONGREGATION.
PHILLIPS HAS A HISTORY OF
CONFRONTATIONS.
FOUR YEARS AGO HE TOLD A SIMILAR
STORY CLAIMING WHITE STUDENTS IN
MICHIGAN DISRESPECTED HIM AND
THREW A BEER CAN AT HIM.
HE WENT TO POLICE, BUT NO
EVIDENCE TURNED UP TO SUPPORT
HIS CLAIM.
HE HAS A RAP SHEET INCLUDING
NEGLIGENT DRIVING CHARGES.
THERE HAS BEEN CONFUSION OVER
HIS SERVICE DURING THE VOTE NAME
ERA.
PHILLIPS CLAIMED HE SERVED IN
VIETNAM AND WAS THE VICTIM OF
UGLY PROTESTS UPON RETURNING.
>> I AM A MARINE CORPS VET.
I GOT AN HONORABLE DISCHARGE.
WHAT MY BOX SAYS IS I WAS IN
THEATER.
I DON'T TALK MUCH ABOUT MY
VIETNAM TIMES.
WHEN I COME HOME, THOSE TIMES, I
GOT SPIT ON.
ACTUALLY SPIT ON, CALLED A BABY
KILLER.
JESSE: THE MARINES SAY PHILLIPS
WAS A RESERVIST FROM 1972 TO
976.
WORKED ON REFRIGERATORS
STATESIDE, NEVER DEPLOYED.
AND HE WENT AWOL SEVERAL TIMES.
HE WAS ASKED TO CLARIFY HIS
SERVICE RECORD.
>> I ALWAYS SAID I NEVER STEPPED
FOOT IN SOUTH VIETNAM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH CLEAR CAN
THAT BE?
JESSE: HE COULD HAVE BEEN A SLOT
CLEARER THERE.
IT'S CALLED SOLEN VALOR.
HE'S A PROVOCATEUR.
BUT HE WAS THE SOURCE FOR ALL
THE MAINSTREAM OUTLETS WHO
BOUGHT HIS NARRATIVE WITHOUT ANY
CLARIFICATION AND USED IT TO